la direction à présent la russie où
l'épidémie de comme ils disent neufs
continuent de flamber les chiffres sont
inquiétants pour tenter d'endiguer cette
quatrième vague le gouvernement a décidé
de déclarer une semaine chômé en russie
et ce jusqu'au 7 novembre les précisions
avec notre correspondant à moscou
antoine mackey
la journée de vendredi a enregistré un
nouveau record mille cent soixante trois
personnes sont mortes en 24 heures à
cause du coc vie 19 alors que les
chiffres restent mauvais moscou avait
fermé depuis jeudi tous les services non
essentiels et prier les entreprises de
placer au moins 30 % de leurs effectifs
en télétravail en parallèle à partir de
ce samedi 30 octobre et jusqu'au 7
novembre séjours sont chômés à travers
tout le pays vladimir poutine a
également envoyé le ministre de la santé
ainsi que ses adjoints dans les régions
les plus touchées afin de leur venir en
aide des mesures qui on l'espère du côté
des autorités porteront leurs fruits on
verra l'effet de cette mesure à l'issue
de la période de jours fériés quand les
gens reviendront à moscou nous verrons
son effet nous espérons que nous
pourrons travailler normalement et que
la ville reprendra sa vie normale
cependant il faudra encore du temps pour
mesurer l'impact de ces mesures sur
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
les autorités se veulent optimistes mais
l'allongement dans le temps ou encore
l'évolution de ces restrictions ne sont
pas exclues